[Musique]
bonsoir deux mois deux mois de
confinement strict qu'on vient de vivre
en france et ça fait deux mois qu'on
n'avait pas eu le plaisir de se
retrouver le lundi soir en direct pour
audition publique mais on est ravi de
vous retrouver su pour cette émission du
lundi soir sur lcp public sénat et le
figaro depuis les plateau de lcp est
notre invité pour la reprise aujourd'hui
est un ancien ministre bonsoir patrick
kanner président du groupe ps au sénat
et sénateur du nord le sénat qui a
d'ailleurs donné du fil à retordre au
gouvernement ces derniers temps sur la
prolongation d' état d'urgence sanitaire
on va y revenir
la gauche reproche le manque de mesures
sociales en particulier pendant une
heure en direct
on va évoquer aussi les conséquences de
cette liste du coronavirus du point de
vue économique en particulier dans
quelques instants nous allons retrouver
ta mme tran huy et brigitte boucher des
chaînes parlementaires puis un député et
une sénatrice qui vous interpelleront et
puis yves thréard du figaro à la fin de
cette émission
notez que vous pouvez envoyer comme
d'habitude vos questions vos réactions
sur le figaro.fr avec le hashtag
auditions publiques le tout relayé
depuis la rédaction du figaro live où on
sera tout à l'heure en direct
première question patrick kanner c'est
le jour 1 du déconfinement aujourd'hui
après deux mois de confinement c'est ce
que je disais qu'est ce que vous retenez
vous de ces deux mois déjà d'être
heureux d'être ici c'est important de
retrouver finalement un plateau manière
réelle je reviendrai
cette révolution du travail à distance
qui offrent finalement beaucoup de
facilité mais aussi créer des
contraintes extraordinaire moi en tant
que sénateur
j'ai eu le sentiment de travailler tout
le temps du lundi au dimanche parce que
systématiquement on pouvait contacter
soit par visioconférence voit par contre
cole soit par wasquehal ce soit par un
téléphone classique ceux avec qui on
voulait et on devait travailler donc une
révolution je crois il faudra en tirer
les conséquences et un nouveau mode de
vie et j'ai bien vu les sondages
certains voudraient continuer à
travailler comme cela d'autres
considèrent que c'est une contrainte
extraordinaire par rapport au droit du
travail donc vrai sujet pour l'avenir
on parle de déconfinement il ya quand
même une trentaine de départements en
rouge dont le vôtre
le nord où la le confinement reste à
l'ordre du jour c'est une situation
difficile à vivre pour les habitants du
nord qui voit le reste de la france ceux
des confiné petit à petit les différents
centres est très faible entre un
département vert un département rouge
simplement quitter il était passé du
rouge à l'orangé espérer passer de
laurent jover ils sont repassés au rouge
par décision de l'exécutif non les gens
du nord au sens large du terme d eau d
autres ans savent quels sont leurs
responsabilités et donc ça va les
inciter à être prudent parce que le
virus circule encore beaucoup dans notre
région et que la charge c'est bien de ça
dont il s'agit
la charge sur le lit de réanimation est
encore forte donc prudence attention
danger le virus toujours là on va
accueillir maintenant tam traduit de
public sénat
[Musique]
bon sur table bon ça fera vite vous
retrouvez avec d'abord le l'état
d'urgence sanitaire qui a peut-être du
plomb dans l aile un petit peu en tout
cas le conseil constitutionnel vient de
mettre le holà ça vient de tomber vous
allez nous dire tout ça et puis poser la
question qui va
patrick kanner effectivement bonsoir
patrick kanner cette décision du conseil
constitutionnel qui a validé dans
l'ensemble cette loi mais elle sent smic
sont sur des éléments qui sont liées au
traçage et à l' isolement
alors je précise exactement ce que dit
le conseil constitutionnel concernant
les traitements de données à caractère
personnel de nature médicale aux fins de
traçage il a décidé d'eux censure
partielle pour limiter le nombre de
personnes pouvant accéder à ces données
pour qu'un juge des libertés puisse
effectuer un contrôle
si elle m'avait le malade ne peut pas
sortir plus de douze heures de son lieu
d'isolement votre réaction
tout d'abord c'est une reconnaissance de
la pertinence de notre propre recours
même si on a eu des éléments qui n'ont
pas été prises en compte par le conseil
constitutionnel c'est la règle du jeu
une satisfaction qui ont fait un recours
par définition on sait qu'on aura
peut-être pas raison sur surtout mais ce
que nous voulions dans notre recours
s'est montré que la ligne de crête pour
reprendre une expression bien connue
maintenant entre liberté individuelle et
sécurité sanitaire doit être protégé
donc vous êtes satisfait de la décision
du conseil constitutionnel je vais
d'analyser dans le détail tomber oui
minutes
bien entendu le fait que les données
médicales ne puisse pas si vous allez au
combat parce qu'on ne voulait pas que
trop de personnes puissent avoir accès
aux données médicales et les fameuses
brigades des anges gardiens formule
consacrée par notamment le ministre vers
en moi je préfère parler de suivi
épidémiologique ne peut pas se faire
dans n'importe quelle condition il faut
pas sacrifier les libertés individuelles
à une forme d'efficacité sanitaires sur
une période qui est extrêmement était
vraiment une validation dans son
ensemble ça justifie pour vous votre
recours parce que on pouvait quand même
s'interroger sur la nécessité de ce
recours compte tenu du fait qu'il y
avait eu celui du président de la
république qui avait eu à gérard larcher
et puis ensuite vous là avec notamment
les sénateurs socialistes les sénateurs
communistes
vous n'êtes pas la première journaliste
aujourd'hui me dire mais pourquoi vous
avez fait un recours à 8,3
ce qu'ils avaient besoin s'acharner
autant d'abord tout d'abord j'ai pu lire
le recours de du président larcher qui
d'ailleurs aussi s'interroger sur ces
parties là du sujet qui nous intéresse
ce soir je n'ai pas pu lire le recours
du président macron mais si vous voulez
la constitution nous permet c'est un
bien de pouvoir en tant que sénateur
soixante ou soixante députés déposé un
recours pour vérifier que le texte de
loi est conforme à la loi fondamentale
qu'est la constitution
j'ai toute confiance en monsieur macron
j'ai toute confiance en monsieur larcher
invité politique que vous faites aussi à
votre camp quand vous lisez bien le
recours de monsieur larcher et le nôtre
n'est pas sur les mêmes bases donc il
est normal que l'opposition puisse dans
le cadre de la constitution a interpellé
le conseil façon d'exister c'est pas
d'exister c'est une façon de défendre
des positions qui ne sont pas
automatiquement celle de l'exécutif ou
du président du sénat donc de grâce de
grâce n'enlevons pas cette possibilité
qui a été lourdement acquise et dans de
bonnes conditions vous le savez bien
souvent de 14 encore juste une question
sur cette seule loi de prorogation le
président de la république et le premier
ministre cette mue par communiqué ils
ont dit qu'ils avaient dû prendre des
décrets en urgence car cette loi sur la
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire n'avait pas été promulguée ce
que pour vous c'est un raté et à qui la
faute
un raté qui va se corriger très vite
puisque la communication a donc
finalement ce n'est pas très grave mais
c'est un symbole de la manière dont nous
travaillons aujourd'hui ça va trop vite
et à force de confondre vitesse et
précipitation
on va faire du mauvais travail juridique
le conseil des ministres s'est réuni il
ya une semaine un peu plus d'une semaine
il a fallu réagir en urgence le le
parlement d'abord le sénat puis
l'assemblée nationale puis la commission
mixte paritaire ont dû se réunir dans
les conditions improbable pour aboutir
un recours qui a été déposée hier
dimanche 10 mai avoir été maltraité par
le gouvernement dans cette période je
vous le dis et ça ne peut plus durer ça
ne peut plus durer il faut que le
gouvernement comprenne que
le parlement fait partie de l' équilibre
normal de nos institutions de la vème
république
vous avez des amis le plan d'urgence en
primeur enfin les parlementaires nous
apprendrons tirs entendus dans des
conditions dans quelles conditions
madame encore une fois trop vite avec
des contraintes pour répondre je
considère que aujourd'hui il y a une
forme d' employer le mot de maltraitance
gens tu vois deux déséquilibres dans le
fonctionnement normal des institutions
de la vème alors le 11 mai aujourd'hui
c'est la date du début du déconfinement
il y avait eu débat autour de ça oui
effectivement
et vous vous aviez d'ailleurs demandé
s'il ne fallait pas reporter ce
déconfinement à ce que avec le recul
aujourd'hui vous diriez la même chose le
recul est quand même très léger
reconnaît c'est ce que ça c'est bien
facile aujourd'hui
moi j'étais en conférence téléphonique
avec le préfet de ma région monsieur
michel lalande tout à l'heure et je lui
ai posé la question notamment sur les
écoles et il était rassurant via dont
acte le fait de s'inquiéter ne pas dire
qu'on est contre une date ce que j'ai
reproché notamment à mais je m'accroche
falloir fixer une date
le 11 mai sans avoir fait de rétro
planning finalement sur toute l'action
nécessaire du gouvernement pour aboutir
un bon déconfinement donc aujourd'hui
manifestement y compris dans les
transports les choses semblent bien
passé j'ai envie de dire tant mieux pour
notre pays mais c'était un pari à hauts
risques
permettez moi quand même de prendre un
peu de distance avec les événements nous
verrons peut-être dans deux ou trois
jours ci les choses bien passé ça s'est
bien passé dans les transports on a eu
tout de même aussi ces images notamment
dans le métro dans l'erreur en
ile-de-france pour vous écouter la ligne
13 a été saturé pendant quelques
dizaines de minutes manifestement liée à
un incident technique lié aux grandes
pluies de cette nuit à paris je ne tire
pas comme ça en permanence je reconnais
qu'il peut y avoir des impératifs des
impondérables
dont acte mais ce qui est important
c'est que les français ont été
responsables et c'est un message qui
doit être adressé ainsi au gouvernement
ne pas considérer les français comme
infantile les français savent prendre
leurs responsabilités et on a vu que 95
% d'entre eux portaient des masques de
l'étrange mais vous souhaitez une
commission denquête parle effectivement
c'était une commission denquête vous
voulez qu'elle début
fin mai début juin est ce que vous avez
une date à nous communiquer ce qu'on
sait quand est-ce qu'elle va commencer
écouter la conférence des présidents au
sénat l'a décidé dans son principe le 29
avril dernier
nous allons avoir une nouvelle
conférence mercredi qui devrait fixer
son déroulement
moi je souhaite qu'elle se déroule le
plus vite possible c'est-à-dire qu'elles
se réunissent dès le mois de juin
pourquoi pour nous permettre d'avoir six
mois complet de travail avant le vote du
futur projet de loi de finances de
sécurité sociale ans c'est une durée
maximale de six mois pour auditionner
pour enquêter
est ce que ça ne va pas être trop court
si par eyong épidémie se poursuit est ce
qu'elle ne risque pas d'avoir des
conclusions caduque tel à l'épidémie va
se poursuivre et en personne ne peut
savoir ni ici ni ailleurs comment elle
va se dérouler malheureusement s'est
passé quand même de commencer non parce
que les questions que nous avons posées
sur par exemple la gestion des masques
cette crise qui est qui est réel le
nombre de tests qui a été pratiqué
pendant de nombreuses semaines ou encore
la tenue d'épreuves des élections
municipales
ce sont des éléments qui relèvent du
passé alors ils ont besoin de savoir les
masques justement oui justement parce
que les masques aujourd'hui de façon
présente
ils sont soit pas assez nombreux on a eu
beaucoup de problèmes bien sûr de
pénurie soit on a vu aussi qu'il ya eu
des problèmes de masques défectueux par
exemple notamment à la mairie de paris
ces masques qualifié par certains élus
de sopalin est ce que vous vous juger
qu'il ya un gros problème est-ce que
vous jugez qu'on peut parler d'un même
de scandale d'état
le mot est fort en tout cas il y a un
problème d'état pour être très clair il
y avait 750 millions de masques
chirurgicaux en stock à la fin du
quinquennat de françois hollande
et si on doit le prouver on le prouvera
et monsieur
philippe a évoqué qu'au début de
l'épidémie c'est à dire fin janvier
début février
nous étions à 117 millions de masques
chirurgicaux donc il y a eu un problème
600 millions de moins 600 millions de
masques ont disparu vous vous demandez
quand vous étiez ont été détruits mais
quand vous dites que vous aurez les
moyens de le prouver vous êtes en train
de faire un dossier là bien sûr c'est à
dire bien sûr vous et moi j'ai appartenu
à un gouvernement jusqu'à la fin du mois
de mai 2000 2010 est de vous êtes en
train de faire les éléments de défense
là vous avez un grand journal du soir
qui avait déjà lu mon déjà quelques
éléments
oui sur quatre pages complètes donc oui
vous avez entendu la réponse d'olivier
ferrand qui a dit ces masques étaient
pour certains dans un état tel qu'on
n'aurait pas pu les données là qu'il
faudra aussi le le prouver ce que je
sais c'est que quand on détruit des
masques on doit reconstituer les stocks
et la vraie question elle est là
peut-être que ces masques devaient être
détruits mais il fallait à ce qu'on a
les rencontres tu es en stock pour faire
face à une épidémie esna cela n'a pas
été fait manifestement donc un vrai
sujet pour cette commission enquête
une dernière question d'âme oui une
dernière question peut être sûr et bien
vous votre difficulté peut-être à
trouver le bon ton est ce que on l'a vu
le consentement l'acceptabilité des
français aux règles qui ont été
instaurés il est essentiel pour que tout
cela fonctionne quelle est votre
position
comment trouver le bon ton entre
critique et en même temps responsabilité
pour eux le rôle de l'opposition est
d'être un élément de d'interpellations
sinon on en sort est dans une forme de
démocrature été moi l'expression
donc nous faisons notre travail mais
simplement ce que nous disons au
gouvernement c'est que les français ne
sont pas irresponsables et vous donner
un exemple très concret l'ouverture des
plages que n'ai-je entendu de la part de
monsieur véran dans le débat
parlementaire de la semaine dernière
nous disant mais les français vont pas
respecter les consignes de sécurité mais
arrêtons de prendre les français pour
des enfants voire pire quand ils sont
sur les plages et ça va être ouvert dès
cette semaine
eh bien vous verrez qu'ils auront un
comportement responsable donc moi ce que
j'attends c'est que le gouvernement
prenne de bonnes décisions fixe un cap
et fasse confiance à nos concitoyens
merci dame merci francis bonne rentrée
c'est une espèce de rentrer un petit peu
dans un sens on retrouvera brigitte
boucher qui va vous succès d'état mais
avant ça on va faire un détour par le
figaro live où nous attend vincent roux
bonsoir vincent vous vous avez l'oeil
rivé sur ce qu'il se dit sur vos sites
et les réseaux sociaux alors quels sont
les thèmes et les questions qui
ressortent le plus au cours de ces
dernières heures alors ses dernières
heures francis il flottait une odeur de
soufre
une odeur de soufre en région parisienne
et également à paris alors ça a suscité
pas mal de commentaires pas mal d'une
hernie aussi notamment à l'encontre de
la politique d' anne hidalgo et avec
cette odeur de souffre également très
commenté les dernières intempéries mais
c'est bien sûr et bien évidemment le
déconfinement qui est très suivie et
très commentée par les internautes et en
particulier les mesures annoncées
aujourd'hui par le ministre de
l'économie et par les membres du
gouvernement et notamment cette mesure
cette idée de bruno le maire qu'on a pu
entendre d'ailleurs sur figaro live ce
matin l'idée de subordonner l'aide de
l'aide de l'état aux entreprises aux
entreprises qui relocalisent ray qu'est
ce que vous en pensez vous patrick
kanner african air on est en train de
redécouvrir l'état providence et la
notion de souveraineté économique
j'ai envie de dire si une forme de
lucidité qui peut plaire un keynésien
que je suis naturellement
simplement on ne passe pas d'un système
mondialisé un système autonome en
claquant des doigts
et donc je peux comprendre la position
de monsieur le maire qui le dira mais
prenant en compte des critères écologie
c'est aussi le cas dans d'autres dans
d'autres moments retrouvons une forme de
souveraineté nationale et moi pour moi
je j'aimerais plutôt une souveraineté
européenne parce que je crois à l'europe
je pense qu'on peut relocaliser des
entreprises au niveau européen ce qui
permettrait aussi de montrer l'utilité
de l'europe en tout cas je me méfie
comme de la peste de l'idée que
finalement la fermeture des frontières
prôné par notamment l'extrême droite
serait considérée comme étant la
solution l'alpha et l'oméga nos
problèmes fermeture des frontières
économiquement on voulait dire quelles
frontières économiquement mais on sait
très bien que ça veut dire aussi
peut-être à terme mettre à bas tout
l'apport de l'europe savoir la libre
circulation des biens et des personnes
façon oui vous trouve où trouver
finalement que bruno le maire est trop
souverainiste dans cette dans cette
annonce souverainiste je le souhaiterais
qu'il soit au niveau européen je
voudrais pas encore une fois compost
vous avez dès qu'il ya aussi quand même
des pays qui se font en concurrence en
europe
vous savez bien cru de poule quand eva
en pologne par exemple c'est en europe
mais vous avez vu ce que ça donne oui
mais encore une fois on ne pourra pas
recueil qu'alizé toute l'entreprise
française
en tout cas l'entreprise nécessaire à la
france en france lire sinon ce sera une
fermeture complète de nos relations et
nous arriverons à ce moment-là à une
concurrence effrénée avec la création à
nouveau de droit douanes ce serait
mettre à bas toute la création de
l'union européenne et ça je ne peux pas
l'accepter
bien merci vincent d'être intervenus
depuis la rédaction du figaro live dont
vous êtes le rédacteur en chef
on accueille maintenant brigitte boucher
de lcp
[Musique]
bon soit en régie sincères prince il est
ravi de vous retrouver aussi également
moins saint-patrick nerfs on va
commencer à part parler d'économie
puisque vous venez déjà d'en parler un
petit peu avec notre confrère du figaro
live aujourd'hui le gouvernement a dit
que la vie économique devait reprendre
est ce que vous considérez que pour vous
c'est aussi la priorité bien sûr que
c'est une priorité le confinement ne
pouvait pas durer des mois et des mois
risque de l'effondrement pour reprendre
l'expression qui était utilisé à la
santé publique doit primer sur center
non c'est anne passe vous non je veux
dire par là c'est qu'il faut trouver un
équilibre
oui vous avez dit ça oui mais attendez
aujourd'hui nous avons 12 millions de
nos concitoyens qui ont fait une demande
de chômage partiel
une grande partie d'entre eux l'ont
obtenue ou vont vont l'obtenir c'est la
moitié de plus de la moitié des salariés
du secteur privé
ces personnes n'ont rien demandé une
décision administrative qui les a forcés
à aller au chômage partiel en perdant
d'ailleurs pour beaucoup d'entre eux une
partie de leurs revenus sauf pour les
personnes qui sont au niveau du smic en
terme de deux salaires donc les
entreprises vont beaucoup souffrir
certaines vont repartir parce que la
différence de l'état de guerre que nous
avons connu pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale et le déconfinement entre
guillemets de 1945 si vous voulez
permettre une comparaison un peu osé
notre système industriel existe il n'ya
pas une destruction de vies il n'y a pas
eu destruction de aïn crise actuelle et
par c'est pas une crise économique au
départ donc il faut il faut reprendre
simplement ce que je peux demander ce
que je dois demander au gouvernement
c'est d'accompagner en particulier les
salariés il faut que les chefs
d'entreprise puissent retrouver bien sûr
des marges de manoeuvre il faut que les
faces sentent milliards soixante
milliards d'économie des français
pendant cette période
c'est énorme les français ont économisé
il faut que les français est envie de re
consommé et que donc il faut que la vie
reprenne dans notre pays mais mais il
n'y a pas de traitement
il n'y a pas de vaccin et donc les
français qui vont reprendre le travail
qu'ils soient fonctionnaires ou salariés
du privé doivent être
protéger et donc c'est donc ils donc des
masques pour tout le monde c'est ça que
ça veut dire à moi j'ai moi je suis très
clair là dessus c'est des masques pour
tout le monde
gratuit partout gratuitement et dans
tout l'espace public alors à propos de
reprise de reprise' parfois il ya des
grains de sable notamment chez renault
sandouville a lâché renault sandouville
puisque la justice a tranché le travail
ne reprend pas la cgt a considéré que
les conditions sanitaires elles
n'étaient pas réunies et bruno le maire
a trouvé que c'était une mauvaise
décision pour vous aussi
mais elle devrait pas commenter les
décisions de justice en tant que membre
de big beauty fils devrait respecter la
séparation des c'est une faute de la
part du miz économique va en tout cas on
ne commente pas une décision de justice
auront de la décision de la cgt de
saisir la justice
ça c'est cgt et dans son créneau à titre
personnel
moi je suis plus proche d'autres
syndicats gel va trop loin la cgt je
considère donc je dis pas qu'elle va
trop loin puisqu'elle a eu gain de cause
dans la justice je pense que l' usine va
faire appel probablement en la matière
simplement ça vous montre la difficulté
du moment
il faut que les salariés et leurs
représentants soient rassurés sur les
conditions de reprise du travail et sa
longue vous dites que la cgt a
finalement eu raison
je dis simplement que justice lui a
donné raison c'est une lapalissade mais
c'est maintenant mes dires la cgt a fait
une démarche qui a été reconnue par par
la justice dont donc à l'arrêt cela peut
choquer dans le contexte actuel mais je
ne peux moi que constater que les
arguments de la cgt ont été prises en
considération par le gisti tendu on
parle de l'école aussi puisque l'école
dé confine à partir de demain les
maternelles à l'école élémentaire qui va
reprendre progressivement est ce que
pour vous comme pour le conseil
scientifique d'ailleurs l'école n'aurait
dû reprendre qu'au mois de septembre le
coup scientifique est entendue parfois
il ne l'ait pas entendu parfois aussi
donc j'espère que ce n'était pas un
conseil décoratifs
permettez moi l'expression en fonction
des opportunités politiques autant il
faut bien prendre des décisions
politiques on peut pas toujours se ville
aussi ondes et les excès mais moi s'il
voulait très très bien sûr qu'il faut
que les politiques prennent leurs
responsabilités on a eu beaucoup
d'expressions chaotique sur la reprise
des écoles beaucoup d'anxiété qui a été
rajoutée à l'anxiété naturel d
rang mais aussi des enseignants avec
personnel mais je pense que je serai
entendu par beaucoup de personnes qui
nous écoutent ici je considère qu' on ne
pouvait pas avoir une reprise d'école
comme sa pile ou face
sur un coup de dés et notamment basé sur
le volontariat où on ouvre on n'ouvre
pas qu'il aurait faite en septembre
il ya un risque pour les enfants je vous
le dirai plus tard je pense que chacun
fait au mieux mais le chacun fait au
mieux en faisant qu'il n'y ait pas de
plus de 10 de 15 élèves par classe en
fonction de l'âge des enfants
c'est une reprise disons le de
l'éducation nationale que je
qualifierais de dégrader en termes
d'argent
je suis pour mais prendre la question de
briller tant mieux pour les enfants fait
les reprendre en septembre alors plutôt
oui ou non je pense que oui je pense que
oui je pense que oui serait et et
reprendre pour tout le monde
reprendre tout le monde mais je ne
mesure bien que la reprise de l'école
c'est aussi permettre des parents de
retrouver le chemin de duab provient
cette histoire l'économie avant que le
pédagogie pour la santé c'est un mélange
extrêmement compliqué à mettre en place
en tout cas aujourd'hui l'école de la
république obligatoire ne l'est pas pour
tout le monde mais c'est un peu contre
ce que vous dites est ce que comment
reprendre l'économie si les enfants
restent à la maison et peut les parents
doivent aussi vous avez bien compris que
tout le monde ne rentrait pas
aujourd'hui que c'était par classe d'âge
et que notamment dans les départements
rouge
les élèves ne rentrait pas dans les
collèges donc tout ceci est extrêmement
complexe complexité que j'accorde qui
ait pas de malentendus au gouvernement
aujourd'hui d'où les discours
extrêmement contradictoires parfois ici
ou là
simplement il nous faudra du recul pour
voir si cette mesure était la bonne le
11 mai on va parler maintenant de ce
dont on a beaucoup parlé pendant cette
crise ce sont les soignants les
personnels d pad notamment tous ceux qui
étaient au premier rang j'allais dire
entre autres oui alors il ya des primes
qui ont été annoncées pour pour ces
soignants ses personnels d pad
est ce que vous pensez vous qu'il faut
de vraies augmentations de salaires il
faut une reconnaissance qui ne soit pas
que par la prime c'est à dire la prime
c'est une reconnaissance très ponctuel
tant mieux pour celles et ceux qui vont
en profiter
elle est payée par l'état c'est un
effort réel de l'état en la matière
simplement ces personnels sont payés
excusez moi avec la statue au
lance-pierre qu'il faut augmenter les
salaires de ses personnels il faut
revoir le statut de ces personnels si on
considère que ces premières lignes pour
reprendre l'expression consacrée à
caractère guerrier aujourd'hui est la
bonne expression
eh bien il faut reconnaître que le
service public où le service d'intérêt
général porté par ses personnels
d'autres ont connu bien plus qu'il ne
l'est aujourd'hui c'est à dire et qui
finance
on est on est pas on n'est pas là pour
déterminer à sur ce plateau avec tout le
respect que je vous dois
qui doit payer simplement ce que je sais
c'est que aujourd'hui l'impôt doit être
réhabilité pour permettre que ce service
public à la française
cette dépense publique à la française
soit beaucoup plus se présente
aujourd'hui notre vie quotidienne
combien de fois avons nous entendu qu'on
dépensait trop on dépenser trop pour le
service public et fait maintenant 1
alors il nous montre qu'il est aussi
dans notre modèle pas d'être il ya aussi
les caissières il ya aussi les
caissières oui elle beaucoup pas mais
justement est-ce qu'il faut augmenter le
smic finalement pour tous ces métiers là
je tiens à vous dire qu'il n'ya pas eu
de coup de pouce au smic depuis le début
du quinquennat et donc vous préconisez
une augmentation du smic bien sûr après
il faut déterminer avec corps
intermédiaires les forces syndicales
qu'elle doit être cette augmentation
bien sûr ça on entend des chiffres ici
ou là la question c'est la
reconnaissance aujourd'hui
et moi je me refuse à considérer que
comme par hasard dans une amnistie
générale dans une amnésie générale on
oublierait qu'il n'y a jamais eu de coup
de pouce au smic pendant ce quinquennat
qui n'a pas eu d'augmentation du point
d'indicé des fonctionnaires dans ce
quinquennat et que par miracle
tout ceci sera oublié
et qu'on allait vivre des jours heureux
pour reprendre l'expression et ses nerfs
patrick kanner il y a deux mois lors de
la dernière d'auditions publiques avant
le confinement des confinement en début
dé confinement aujourd'hui vous savez
comment parler de la réforme des
retraites et donc la réforme des
retraites mais cette réforme des
retraites
on l'attend encore est ce que vous
pensez qu'il faut l'abandonner ou la
reprendre là où on en était resté clair
que pour nous c'est l'abandon ces mêmes
l'abrogation de toute démarche
velléitaire visant à la mettre en oeuvre
moi je suis favorable à ce que j'ai
toujours défendu cette grande conférence
sociale et territoriale
depuis elles perdent et gilet jaune pour
mettre en place notre système social
faire que ce qu'on reconnaît aujourd'hui
soit effectivement reconnu dans leurs
statuts et dans leur pouvoir d'achat
la réforme des retraites était une
réforme injuste pour l'instant elle
n'est pas enterrée comme n'est pas
enterrer la réforme de l'assurance
chômage
elle doit l'être également mais bien sûr
encore une fois puisqu'on veut un
nouveau monde par rapport au monde
d'avant à l'ancien monde
encore faut-il qu'on donne des signes et
à ce stade je n'entends pas ces signes
porté par le gouvernement si on veut
apaiser et redonner confiance en
français est bien en remettons les
compteurs à zéro à propos de confiance
les sondages que vous avez regardé et
brigitte oui les sondages qui donnent
une cote de popularité comprises entre
34 et 41 % selon les instituts cote de
confiance du gouvernement
quand on regarde c'est toujours mieux
que françois hollande dont vous avez été
le ministre finalement même après les
attentats de 2015 où il avait rebondi
donc finalement c'est une défiance qui
est un peu relative la comparaison n'est
par exemple si vous comparez avec les
autres pays européens et la confiance
des des citoyens dans les autres pays
européens
on est entre guillemets les plus mauvais
en la matière non ça va le juge de paix
c'est l'élection et les sondages sont un
indicateur mais la vérité qui qui
s'imposera à nous et on l'a vu déjà aux
élections municipales on en reparlera
sûrement tout à l'heure
et bien c'est le choix des français dans
légion
merci brigitte merci de m'avoir prêté
votre place aussi que vous retrouverez
dans les questions gouvernement promis
preuve il promis merci et à lundi pour
audition publique auditions publiques
c'est aussi le lieu où des
parlementaires sont au coeur des débats
et viennent interpeller nos invités de
patrick kanner
vous allez avoir en face de vous ce soir
dominique estrosi sassone qui est
sénatrice et l'ère des alpes-maritimes
et bruno myle yen qui est député modem
des yvelines bonsoir à tous les deux
merci d'être avec nous en duplex grâce
aux réseaux sociaux skype en
l'occurrence je crois que tous les deux
vous êtes branchés comme ça c'est
dominique estrosi-sassone qui va vous
poser une première question concernant
l'économie parce que la question de
savoir s'il faut travailler plus
n'est-ce pas oui bonsoir patrick kanner
bon choix alors que les français
commencent aujourd'hui progressivement à
ceux des confiner le redémarrage
économique
on le sait va être l'eau et il va être
graduelle on voit bien combien la crise
est énorme avec des faillites en cascade
avec des finances publiques qui sont au
rouge
avec le chômage qui est en éruption je
considère pour ma part que le
gouvernement a plutôt bien agi depuis le
début de cette crise en matière
économique parce qu'il a pris des
mesures d'aidé de soutien d'urgence pour
éviter autant que faire se peut de faire
en sorte qu'il y ait trop d'entreprises
françaises comporte trop atteinte à
l'appareil de production
mais pour autant je pense que pour qu'il
y ait un redressement durable il faut
travailler plus à leurs questions
il faut qu'il y ait plus de sueur
sodefor votre question et en travaillant
plus ordonne aussi un pouvoir d'achat
supplémentaire aux salariés
alors on va en venir aux 35 heures
monsieur le président un kader est ce
que pour vous c'est toujours un sujet
tabou que les 35 heures de ne pas y
toucher
alors est-ce que vous pensez que ce plan
de relance économique va nous permettre
enfin d'ouvrir le débat sur la réduction
du temps de travail on laisse patrick
kanner vos réponses
ma chère collègue
c'est manifestement pour vous que les 35
heures sont un sujet tabou
les 35 heures sont un droit qui
d'ailleurs n'a jamais été remis en
question par les gouvernements que vous
avez soutenu
j'en prends acte et j'en suis
particulièrement heureux je considère
que les 35 heures aujourd'hui peuvent
pas être agité devant les salariés qui
ne sont pour rien dans la situation
économique et sociale dans laquelle il
se retrouve aujourd'hui permettez-moi de
le dire ce serait une une double peine
on peut demander des heures
supplémentaires mais si j'ai bien
compris le projet politique qui est
porté par ehlers et on passerait de 35 à
37 heures et pas de manière ponctuelle
manière permanente comme d'ailleurs vous
avez évoqué l'allongement de l'âge de la
retraite de deux ou trois ans j'ai envie
de vous est conforme avec votre projet
politique et je le respecte ce n'est pas
le mien
donc pas touche aux 35 heures il ne faut
pas travailler plus il faut que tout le
monde puisse travailler et ça c'est une
offre pas toucher aux 35
on ne touche pas aux 35 heures vous avez
votre réponse alors bonhomie lienne vous
vouliez parler de différents sujets mais
tout à l'heure patrick kanner a évoqué
l'idée d'une conférence sociale et ça
c'est une idée que vous aviez misé ya
quelques mois non oui absolument bonsoir
patrick cardon soir c'est une idée qu'on
avait émise en décembre au plus fort de
grève contre les retraites justement où
patrick mignola et notre président de
groupe et puis des députés udf à
l'assemblée nationale nous avions lancé
cette idée de conférence sociale
conférence sociale et salariale
d'ailleurs à laquelle on aurait souhaité
voir venir évidemment tous les groupes
politiques mais également tous les
syndicats et à l'époque ya pas eu
beaucoup de retentissement on en a pas
beaucoup entendu parler finalement vous
n'avez pas pris la balle au bond et ça
m'a intéressé justement que vous
reveniez là dessus parce que nous
peut-être contrairement à vous qui
parlez d'une augmentation du smic
pourquoi pas il faut voir ça s'étudie on
serait plutôt favorable à un
intéressement à partagent finalement des
dividendes
pour toutes tailles d'entreprises et à
tous les salariés reste à en définir
évidemment les principes et le
pourcentage voudrais avoir votre avis
là-dessus
merci pour votre question mon chat
collègues députés de la majorité
sauf erreur mais quand je vous entends
s'il n'y a pas d'erreur quand je vous
entends je me dis mais que faites vous
dans cette majorité qui a créé la flat
tax donc le plafonnement des revenus du
capital qui a supprimé lisf bon je bats
ou fermés éléments de langage vous les
connaissez par coeur
et quand vous dites partage des
dividendes
j'ai envie de souscrire à ce à ce projet
et c'est pour cela je l'évoqué tout à
l'heure que dès le mois de novembre 2018
nous prendra christ et gilet jaune avec
la cfdt et d'autres nous demandions une
grande conférence sociale et
territoriale pour remettre les syndicats
autour de la table on vous dit banco à
bruno myle yens non seulement je dis
banco mais il vient sur la ligne que
nous avions défendu à une autre époque
ce qui est certain c'est que la solution
ne viendra pas d'en haut et que et
viendra pas du président la république
voulait dire elle doit venir d'un cap
fixé par le président ça il est légitime
il a raison et il est dans son rôle mais
simplement le grand débat pour revenir à
cette grande messe autour du président
qui a eu lieu pendant plusieurs mois
le grand débat aura abouti à quoi
finalement à très peu de chose vous le
reconnaîtrez monsieur letellier est donc
cette conférence sociale et territoriale
parce que je pense qu'il faut associer
les élus locaux me paraît être une très
bonne piste de travail pour l'avenir
bien alors il ya des rapprochements qui
sont visiblement dominique
estrosi-sassone on vous retrouve parce
que à propos de l'impôt de solidarité
sur la fortune qui a été supprimée
patrick kanner l'évoqué là tout à
l'heure en répondant à bruno myle yens
et vous avez une question à lui poser là
dessus
oui parce que je vois que patrick kanner
a de nouveau demandé le rétablissement
de bsf en tout cas que les personnes les
plus fortunées dans notre pays participe
davantage à l'effort national et donc le
rétablissement de cet isf
est ce que vous ne pensez pas justement
que l'isf est particulièrement injuste
que ce qui permet aujourd'hui de pouvoir
faire en sorte que l'on comble la dette
abyssal de notre pays ce n'est pas
d'augmenter les impôts mais c'est au
contraire de créer de la richesse
et est ce que cet isf ne va pas au
contraire s'il venait à être rétablie
faire en sorte qu'il y aurait moins
d'investissements en france et que ça
pourrait être aussi un handicap pour
l'emploi à une période où
malheureusement notre pays va connaître
du chômage est ce que finalement la
véritable justice fiscale c'est pas tant
d'avoir supprimé lé isf comme l'a fait
le président manuel macro mais c'est
avant qu'on paye et 7e cette suppression
a des millions de retraités en
augmentant la csg patrick hemmer mais il
ne fallait pas aussi augmenter la la cg
ça je suis évidemment d'accord avec vous
macha collègues les sf c'est un symbole
liez fc 2 milliards 3 milliards d'euros
à l'échelle de toutes nos difficultés
naturellement ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
suffisant mais on ne peut pas demander
aux français de faire des efforts alors
qu'ils voient que les plus fortunés
d'entre ceux qui depuis le début du
quinquennat on récupère et je crois
qu'il ya 100 familles françaises qui ont
récupéré plus d'un million un million et
demi d'euros de pouvoir d'achat en plus
par par an ce n'est pas possible et je
pense que encore une fois ce n'est pas
l'effet économique de l'île et cf qui
m'intéresse c'est le symbole qu'il
représente
symbole que votre gouvernement que le
gouvernant que vous avez soutenu pendant
cinq ans avec monsieur sarkozy n'avait
même pas osé toucher en tant qu' en tant
que tel
ce n'est pas la seule solution bien
évidemment la vraie solution c'est de
creux réhabiliter l'impôt jouer c'est un
symbole vous dites je c'est un symbole
mais je ne crois pas à la baisse des
impôts
je le dis très simplement je crois d
impôt plus juste
je pense que notre modèle social repose
sur des grands services publics que
maintenant chacun revendique comme étant
absolument nécessaire dès qu'il ya une
crise on re découvre l'état providence
et je veux qu en redécouvrant l'état
providence
on met de côté l'état pénitence qui
était en train d' à ce prêt doit être
plus un petit mot dominique
estrosi-sassone sur le côté symbole de
l' isf qu'est ce que vous répondez vous
moi je pense que c'est un c'est un peu
court comme argument et je dirai
simplement puisque patrick anr a fait
référence à côté de la solution fiscale
qui doit être avant tout juste
effectivement je pense que les solutions
fiscales doivent être avant tout juste
mais soit on baisse les impôts pour tout
le monde soit me semble-t-il
on ne les baisse pas mais je vous donne
un autre exemple
estrosi tous les français quelles que
soient leurs revenus à terme ne vont
plus payer de taxe d'habitation et je
pense qu'on pourra se retrouver là
dessus la taxe d'habitation c'est un
impôt qui permet aux villes d'être
autonome et de pouvoir mener des
politiques publiques en direction de
leurs concitoyens la suppression que je
qualifierais 10 des logiques de la taxe
d'habitation
mais les villans une situation de
dépendance par rapport à l'état et moi
qui est comme comme parlementaire des
revenus qui me permettent de payer ma
taxe d'habitation
j'ai envie de vous dire à ce micro il ya
aucune raison que des personnes telles
que nous nous qui sommes parlementaire
nous puissions pas continuer bien
contribuer au fonctionnement de nos
communes donc l'impôt doit être
réhabilité c'est un lien tout trouvé
pour vous bonhomie viennent les communes
les maires les élus locaux les décideurs
vous avez vu tout à l'heure un conseil
constitutionnel a validé l'essentiel mis
à part le suivi des malades du projet de
loi 2 de la loi pardon de d'état du
détergent d'urgence sanitaire mais il y
a un aspect qui faisait débat c'est la
responsabilité des maires et des
décideurs notamment
oui à ce sujet et patrick kanner ne me
contredira pas il ya eu un large débat à
la fois au sénat remet au parlement et
entre le cnl parlement pendant la
commission mixte paritaire moi je
voulais savoir si finalement le
[Musique]
l'écriture qu'on a trouvé finalement
tout ensemble les deux chambres lors de
la commission mixte paritaire sur la
responsabilité des élus et pas que des
élus des entrepreneurs aussi vous
satisfait ou est ce qu a votre avis il
fallait en rester purement et simplement
à la loi fauchon
alors pour que tout le monde comprenne
la loi fauchon qui date de 2000 est une
loi donc qui a été créée et imaginée au
sénat par monsieur fauchon permettant en
fait d'encadrer la responsabilité pénale
des décideurs locaux ayant paru de les
limiter
des mets pas de la limite et d'encadrer
de savoir où ils vont jusque vers un
maire qui fait une faute grave
un maire qui par négligence ne prend pas
toutes les bonnes mesures il est
pénalement responsable
mais la décision
les décisions multiples comprennent que
prennent des maires doivent être
encadrés sur le lien alors par contre ce
que vous demandez donc là dans le texte
initial du projet de loi d'urgence il
n'y avait pas cet encadrement
complémentaires et nous avons considéré
le temps
les sénateurs de droite et l'air au
sénat que les socialistes et les
sénateurs communistes qu' il fallait
dans une période particulière faire que
ce qui allait appliquer les décisions
venant d'en haut en matière de prise en
charge de la sécurité sanitaire sur le
terrain ne soit pas mise en cause parce
qu'ils auraient éventuellement nommé ne
pas respecter telle ou telle page sans
vous parler des maires me bruno myle y
est vous parliez aussi au delà des mers
oui absolument par dont 106 l'hôtellerie
au dessus des mers ce que tous les
décideurs publics qu'ils soient élus ou
pas est-ce que c'est est ce que cette
écriture sur laquelle on est tombé et
qui finalement rentrer dans le code de
la santé vous satisfait ou pas voilà
tout simplement je ne vous cache pas que
je préférais l'écriture issue d'abord de
la première lecture au sénat montchoisi
lag
c'est à dire une écriture qui ne se
basait pas sur les connaissances
scientifiques du moment pour être très
clair la semaine nationale a voulu
rajouter un alinéa laissant entendre que
la responsabilité ne pouvait pas être
engagée si les connaissances
scientifiques n'étaient pas à la hauteur
des décisions qui ont été prises pour
être très clair
je vous donne un exemple au moment où on
a tenu les élections municipales
on a dit le conseil scientifique
permettez cette cette élection et on
s'est basé là dessus et moi je considère
que c'est trop simple de se dédouaner de
ses responsabilités en s'appuyant sur le
conseil pratique de ces trop simple de
se dédouaner qui se dédouane en
l'occurrence en l'occurrence les membres
du gouvernement d'accord et pour être
très très clair
l'ale ce qui est sorti de la commission
mixte paritaire selon notre
interprétation ce n'est pas
l'interprétation du conseil
constitutionnel je le reconnais mais
notre interprétation c'est de permettre
éventuellement des membres du
gouvernement qui aurait pris de
mauvaises décisions qui auraient caché
des choses volontairement ou par
omission de pouvoir être éventuellement
poursuivi je pense que quand on est
membre du gouvernement je l'étais on
doit assumer sa responsabilité mais vous
savez que vous avez un point commun avec
2000 estrosi sassone vous êtes tous les
deux élus d'une région frontalière avec
des des problèmes
différents mais peut-être des problèmes
identiques dominique estrosi sassone oui
je venais de monter à patrick kanner
parce qu'on a vu que cette fermeture des
frontières bien sûr elle a suscité les
débats
elle a été particulièrement mal
coordonnée entre les différents états de
l'union européenne la france a mis du
temps à fermer ses frontières disant que
le virus n'avait pas de frontières on
voit bien que ce sont que c'est la
circulation des hommes et des femmes qui
fait circuler également le virus est
aujourd'hui à l'heure où un certain
nombre de pays de l'union européenne
c'est des cons fils on voit que les
tensions commencent à monter sur les
conditions et le rythme de réouverture
progressive des différentes frontières
au sein de l'union européenne
alors j'ai entendu tout à l'heure un que
vous disiez que la fermeture des
frontières ne devait pas être considéré
comme l'alpha et l'oméga et qu'il
fallait continuer à permettre la libre
circulation des biens et des personnes
mais est ce que vous ne pensez pas que
pour continuer à lutter contre cette
pandémie
il faut quand même maintenir comme c'est
encore le cas aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de contrôles aux frontières
quitte à les assouplir pour les
travailleurs détachés pour les
travailleurs frontaliers mais en mettant
un contrôle par la température contrôler
patrie la destination des personnes pour
savoir où ils vont
mais nous ne sommes pas en désaccord
tant que la pandémie est là tant que le
risque est là il faut avoir des mesures
de contrôle aux frontières
simplement ce que je ne voudrais pas
c'est que nous puissions tirer comme
conséquence que puisque la fermeture des
frontières pour des raisons sanitaires a
été une réussite potentiel eh bien on
considère que finalement chacun doit
rester confiné à vie y compris sur le
plan économique et sur le plan des
libertés européennes dans son dans son
territoire et donc il y à un danger et
je vois bien la petite musique commencé
à sortir notamment sur l'extrême droite
de l'échiquier politique français en
disant mais voyez bien que ça marche de
fermer les frontières mais quand il
s'agira d'aller vendre notre production
à l'étranger et notamment en europe vous
verrez que là les choses iront beaucoup
moins bien et qu'on créera un chômage de
masse par la fermeture des frontières le
le
le réflexe patriotique je peux y croire
y compris sur le plan sanitaire le
réflexe nationaliste je le crains comme
la peste permettez mon expert qui
craignaient aussi dominique
estrosi-sassone vous craignez une dérive
éventuellement vers un réflexe
nationaliste
oui bien évidemment moi je pense aussi
qu'il faut aujourd'hui être extrêmement
prudents sur cette fermeture et ce
contrôle des frontières mais qu'il faut
aussi permettre à l'union européenne de
continuer à faire en sorte que les biens
et les personnes puis le site puisse
circuler librement
ça fera en tout cas peut-être partie des
questions du monde d'après bruno myle
yen à propos du monde d'après on imagine
que ça puisse changer après le
coronavirus oui non on verra c'est
l'avenir qui le dira mais notamment dans
le domaine de l'écologie
oui le domaine de l'écologie ça va être
un domaine absolument capital non je
n'aime pas tellement le terme monde
d'après d'ailleurs il y aura forcément
des il y aura forcément des évolutions
parce que la crise a révélé beaucoup de
choses l'écologie était déjà présente
avant la crise d'ailleurs al commencé à
revenir sur le devant de la scène très
fort on a eu une écologie assez punitive
on va dire réellement depuis le milieu
des années quatre-vingt cinq et il faut
essayer d'inventer nous c'est ce que
nous pensons une écologie positive pour
reprendre une formule
disons que nous sommes pour la
croissance verte et contre la
décroissance sombre voilà je sais pas
celui d'avant la formule vaut ce qu'elle
veut ce qu'elle vaut pardon mais moi
j'ai une petite inquiétude et vous allez
me dire patrick kanner si vous ressentez
la même on sans remonter en terme
d'écologie une écologie assez
dogmatiques qui se passerait finalement
de la vie des citoyens on ne sait pas du
tout ce chemin vers lequel en tout cas
au modem ne voulons aller nous voulons
construire la transition écologique avec
les citoyens avec les citoyens je
reprends un terrain qui vous est cher et
avec les territoires
moi je suis assez content de voir
notamment la réussite des contrats de
transition écologique qui ont été passés
entre le gouvernement et les territoires
on en est aujourd'hui à 80 pour 1
milliard 500 millions d'investissements
pas tout de l'état la moitié des fonds
sont privés donc voilà et puis les
régions vous parlez quand il garder
juste une plante parenthèse bruno
milliards quand vous parler d'écologie
dogmatique donnez moi un exemple vous
parlez de quoi pas ce qui a provoqué on
à moi je pense qu'on a on l'a pas vu
venir parce que tout le monde était
assez d'accord mais
on l'a bien vu ce qui s'est passé avec
la taxe carbone sur les carburants c'est
ce qui a été le déclencheur de la crise
des gilet jaune et honnêtement je pense
qu'on l'a pas vu venir je voulais vous
n'avez pas de retour de tarnos mea culpa
si on avait suivi la ligne qui était
préconisée depuis 2015 il aurait fallu
la faire cette taxe carbone mais bon
vous avez vu le prix du pétrole a flambé
derrière c'est devenu insoutenable pour
évoquer la crise on quitte donc la
trique n avons ri c'est de savoir se
remettre en cause aussi et de revenir
sur des choses qui ne se sont pas bien
passées et d'inventer je termine juste
d'un point flipper évidement pense que
l'écologie l'économie verte sera en plus
une chance tu est énorme pour nos
territoires pour mettre de l'économie
sur des territoires et permettre aux
gens de vivre est alors patrick kanner
est ce que vous y croyez vous à
l'économie vers c'est ça qui vous
demandent j'y crois mais pas avec des
ordres venant d'en haut
je le dis très très simplement je pense
que cette crise sanitaire que nous
venions à montrer aussi un autre chemin
à suivre qui est totalement
complémentaire avec ce qui vient d'être
d'être dit à savoir la place de
collectivité territoriale de notre pays
je ne crois plus depuis bien longtemps à
une sorte de vérité centrale qui
s'imposerait de la même manière sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
et derrière la transition écologique
l'écologie juste et créatrices de
richesses partagées il nous faudra
réfléchir à l'organisation de l'état
c'est un autre immense chantier qu'il
nous faudra préparer dans les semaines
et mois à venir
merci à bruno myle yen et à dominique
estrosi sassone d'avoir été avec nous en
direct pour interroger patrick hannais
remercie d'avoir cette audition publique
de reprise d'après confinement et bon
courage pour la suite de vos travaux
parlementaires
il est l'heure maintenant de voir leur
garde yves thréard qui nous rejoint sur
ce plateau
[Musique]
bonsoir yves bonsoir francis bonsoir
patrick kanner toujours l'approché
torrent et j'ai voulu être en accord
avec vous mais moi ça fait les 30 ans de
la porte voilà je vous ai pas trouvés
très méchant ce soir je vous ai trouvé
plutôt assez conciliant ferme sur vos
fondamentaux les 35 heures et le temps
de travail
certaines choses comme ça mais sur le
reste je vous ai trouvé plutôt assez un
regard à klein on va dire vis-à-vis de
la politique qui est menée par le
conduite par le gouvernement alors j'ai
une question qui n'a pas été posée
les élections municipales normalement le
23 mai fort d'ailleurs d'un conseil du
conseil scientifique qui vous allez nous
en parler eh bien le gouvernement doit
dire si le deuxième tour tant attendu de
ces élections municipales peut avoir
lieu avant la fin du mois de juin
si c'est pas le cas et que c'est reporté
au moins de septembre
il faut refaire deux tours je vais pas
vous faire une réponse de patelins j'ai
bien le thé le l'expression n'est pas
méchante n'est pas méchante mais
d'autant plus que ce que vit le
gouvernement est très difficile à gérer
donc et c'est je crois que c'est
important de le reconnaître sur les
municipales voulez que je réponde sur le
municipal jean louis je vais vous
répondre à côté ça peut être intéressant
c'est intéressant il ne fallait pas te
dire le premier tour à l'asthme ou bien
comme il est fait donc mais parce que
tout est lié
tout est lié vous aviez plaidé pour ceux
de premier tour ait lieu toutes les
forces politiques disaient crient au
scandale à la dictature de monsieur
macron s'il n'avait pas eu lieu
pour l'april vous répondrais sur le
reste ah oui mais ce j'attends la
réponse
nous avons une première réunion à
matignon le 27 février mais où le
premier ministre a réuni ses et
continuent à le faire d'ailleurs les
présidents de groupes socialistes
communistes et leurs groupes de
l'assemblée et du sénat et les chefs de
partis et à plusieurs reprises nous
avons demandé 27 février
oui est ce que les élections municipales
peuvent se tenir et de réunions en
réunions nous avons posé la même
question et à chaque fois les
conditions sont potentiellement réunies
pour qu'elle puisse tenir qui vous
répondez aux ministres l'aveyron et je
le rapadura l'émission jusqu'à la fin en
fait quand il a dit le conseiller
scientifique jusqu'à la fin jusqu'à la
fin vous croyez pas un mot de sa vous
pensez qu'il était beaucoup moins
affirmatif
donc je n'en sais rien d'accord je dis
simplement que tout le monde par contre
savait que si on pouvait éventuellement
tenir le premier tour
on ne pourrait pas tenir le second tour
considérant la courbe de lhenry l'aurait
on aurait devant puisse vous entendre à
ce moment là alors la dimension il
fallait il fallait très concrètement ne
pas d'accord mais maintenant on paie
maintenant au favorable à quoi alors
alors pour ce qui nous concerne nous
tenons respecter ce qui est prévu dans
la loi que nous avons voté à savoir un
rapport le 23 mai et c'est le 23 mai
qu'on pourra savoir si il y aura des
élections le 21 juin
je n'y crois plus un seul instant je
sais que certains jacob l'a dit ce matin
concernent 5000 communes à peu près ça
concerne oui 5000 communes et quand même
17 grandes villes et 17 millions
d'électeurs donc vous n'y croyez plus
fin juin donc vous êtes un parti
dangereux parce qu'on est on est sur une
base d'état d'urgence qui est prolongé
l'état d'urgence se serait terminée oui
très bien où il est prolongé droit de
martine aubry normal que hier soir et
hier disait il faudrait que ça soit
alors le vous avez plusieurs théories là
dessus vous avez ceux qui pensent qu'il
faudrait repousser en septembre tout en
gardant premier tour et ceux qui pensent
comme d'ailleurs l'avis du conseil
d'état qu'il faudrait reporter les jours
les deux tours
martine aubry sait les deux tours
martine aubry s'est clairement entendre
en est dans sa villa elle vient en tête
mais comme pour alli socialiste stéphane
le foll aux mangues johanna rolland à
nantes nathalie appéré en bref en tout
cas vous je lisais le passable
je suis partagé sur le fait qu'on a fait
venir des millions de personnes voter le
15 mars pour du beurre si j'avais peur
si cela n'était pas alors que énormément
de donc voyez je suis très honnête avec
vous à mon avis n'est pas encore
tranchée à ce stade si on se met dans le
cas de figure où ça serait reporté au
mois de septembre
sarr porterait les deux tours ça
reporterait d'autant les élections
sénatoriales qui devait ce oui parce que
les élections sénatoriales peut pas se
faire avec le même corps électoral tous
les trois ans donc moralité ça reporte
de fait l'élection sénatoriale puisque
nous sommes à l'écouté des élus locaux
on a vu à la faveur de cette crise ou à
l'occasion de cette crise parce que
c'est quand même pas une faveur de cette
crise sanitaire que le pouvoir exécutif
est bien se retourner et se tournaient
vers les élus locaux davantage
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui pour
vous et bien marque
si vous voulez le début peut-être d'une
aire - jacobine et fameux pacte
girondins que proposait le président de
la république pendant sa campagne
est-ce qu on y va tout à l'heure je vous
évoquez le grand débat on avait déjà
reconnu les élus locaux à l'époque
et là on s'aperçoit que leur
connaissance du terrain leur efficacité
dans la proximité devait être reconnu je
reviens à ce que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure à savoir quelles relations entre
l'état jacobin son histoire et la
décentralisation celle qui a été porté
par mitterand moroy de faire dans le
début des années 80 et donc c'est un
travail de reconfigurer à sion des
relations entre l'état et les
collectivités qu'il faudra imaginer pour
être clair il faut maintenant donner
plus de pouvoir aux collectivités
territoriales on a beaucoup critiqué
dans quel domaine
on a beaucoup critiqué la réforme de
françois hollande sur la fusion des
régions rappelez-vous continue
d'ailleurs le communiqué mais on a vu on
a vu en tout cas dans cette crise
monsieur
que finalement les régions quelle que
soit leur sensibilité
heureusement qu'elle était forte et
puissante pour porter des solutions en
direction de leurs concitoyens leur
donner davantage de pouvoirs notamment
en termes scolaire comme on le voit
aujourd'hui parce que finalement il ya
beaucoup de maires qui ont dit mais nous
on n'est pas du tout prêts font pas du
tout rouvrir les écoles ligne de crête
et les simples est-ce que nous allons
vers une décentralisation approfondie
qui pourrait aller vers même une forme
de fédéralisme à vous y seriez favorable
de fédéralisme et quand ce dont je suis
sûr c'est que le modèle qui est le nôtre
aujourd'hui par cette crise montre qu'il
est en partie dépassé parce que donc il
nous faut un état qui fixe le cap encore
une fois qui fixe les règles mais qui
s'appuie dans une logique de
subsidiarité pour reprendre un terme
européens sur ceux qui sont les sa
chance qu'ils ont la meilleure
connaissance du terrain à savoir les
élèves aidés à ce processus
est ce que c'est la démonstration
allemande où il ya eu beaucoup moins de
victimes du cornât virus et qui
finalement a été mieux géré et on va le
dire en termes de masse canton de tester
tout ça est ce que c'est cette meilleure
gestion qui vous fait dire ça la cause
n'est pas la même histoire
l'histoire n'est pas n'est pas la même
nous nous sommes construits sur le
centralisme depuis le moyen âge pour
être très clair
un roi puissant qui impose sa volonté
est ce la hâte et traduisent y compris
sous la révolution française par à
pouvoir laïc mais fort donc n'avons pas
la même histoire que nos amis allemands
et puis la comparaison n'est pas raison
quand nous avions cinq mille tests par
jour les allemands étaient entre 50 et
60 mille tests par jour tests
virologiques et donc disons le
clairement on ne peut pas partir d'une
crise très importante pour bâtir des
congrès est ce que vous êtes pour un
nouvel acte ii de la décentralisation
oui décentralisation qui était plutôt la
déconcentration bolliet n'ya eu la
décentralisation de monsieur de faire
il ya eu des aménagements depuis très
peu final un peu est-ce qu'il faut une
troisième vrai avec de nouveaux pouvoirs
confiés aux élus clarification des
ressources pour que ces pouvoirs tout
s'est tu reviens assumer de manière
correcte vous êtes de ceux qui
s'opposaient à kiki est opposé à la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation est
complètement complètement non pas parce
que ce serait un totem et parce qu'il
faut que les collectivités puissent
lever l'impôt je reviens à cette notion
de réhabilitation il ya un enseignement
qu'on a forcément une observation va
dire que cette crise nous donne c'est
que on a eu le sentiment que les forces
de gauche se rassemblait un peu
peut-être pas trop la france assouplisse
moon parti communiste le parti
socialiste les verts les verts d'un est
ce que par exemple ça rebat les cartes
justement pour les élections municipales
est ce que vous pourriez vous rapprochez
ça pourrait changer la donne on a eu un
premier tour terminé dans trente mille
communes
la serre est close et il faut que le
conseil soit installé le plus vite
possible
il nous reste la v10 un peu plus de
quatre mille communes dont beaucoup
d'ailleurs de moins de 1000 habitants
dans ces quatre mille communes qui
doivent aujourd'hui se retrouver moi je
souhaite que ce premier tour du 15 mars
ils devaient être annulés peut-être dans
le cadre d'un second d'un premier d'un
second tour à l'automne soit un
révélateur
la gauche a montré que non seulement
elle résistait bien dans ses fiefs dans
ses bastions mais qu'il était capable
d'aller reconquérir
quand elle était unie la désunion et
mortifère l'union et prolifique donc
s'il fallait tout refaire fallait faudra
faire l'union dès le premier tour à moi
je le souhaiterais en fonction bien sûr
d'accord et programmatique et sur le
plan national il n'y a pas de figure de
proue
ça c'est notre problème le problème ou
de remplacer si vous voulez moi je les
crois deux questions importantes
c'est très grand projet un projet une
stratégie et une incarnation questions
importantes mais alors deux réponses
rapides oui deux voitures la première
vous êtes un ancien ministre des sports
je vous s'est attaché à la pratique
sportive et connaissez cette économie la
bundesliga est le championnat de 1re
division allemande encore les allemands
va reprendre
rudy soir à huis clos mais il reprend il
ya des enjeux commerciaux énormes pas la
france peut-être l'espace garonne
l'italie l'angleterre on sait pas mais
la france va pas reprendre bonne
décision que la france ne prenne pas on
la ligue a pris 7 cette décision qui a
déçu beaucoup de supporters et vous et
moi je je considère qu'on aurait pu
continuer y compris à huis clos
le championnat c'est un pas la décision
qui a été prise c'est noir philippe la
nationale macro edouard philippe doudou
il paraît que c'est celui qui a la cote
aujourd'hui parmi les parlementaires
c'est votre doudou edouard philippe
respecte le parlement et il est vrai que
il est respecté par le parlement disons
que il n'a pas de propos grandiloquents
il n'a pas de propos à caractère martial
ça c'est pour rien on par exemple
merci merci merci et ravi de vous
retrouver aussi ça fait du bien de se
revoir merci patrick kanner c'était
c'est la fin de votre audition publique
merci d'avoir accepté de débattre et de
répondre à nos questions vous pouvez
retrouver toute cette émission sur les
comptes twitter lcp public sénat sur
figaro live audition publique revient
lundi prochain en direct à 19h bonne
soirée
non